we're in the second Cisco County women's
jail right now we're name is about to do
a live recording of her album
Borderlands
my name is Naima Shalhoub I'm a
songstress performing artist and
educator I've been facilitating weekly
music sessions with incarcerated women
in San Francisco County Jail and I'm
going to be recording my first album
called borderlands inside county jail
for incarcerated women what are these
music sessions personally meant to the
women like what have they told you in
terms of how it's impacted them it
really actually blows me away how
meaningful it is just for someone like
me to come in and share songs and it
could be anyone
the other day for example our session
was done and a woman said to me you know
thank you for being my hour of freedom
every week someone another woman has
said once you know I'm leaving the class
I'm saying bye to everyone like bye my
peace and freedom another woman has said
you know I came into class not feeling
great and feeling discouraged and now I
feel a lot better and I feel like I can
get through my day and somehow even with
the struggles and me missing my kids I
feel like there's hope what kind of
insight has this all given you in terms
of the prison system that we have in
this country and what it means to be an
incarcerated person the statistics that
one reads about when you start reading
about how the prison industrial complex
is entrenched with obstacles and and
justices for incarcerated people that
once you're incarcerated
you're basically incarcerated for life
is true I wanted to offer this music for
you I've been working with a lot of you
all the last year volunteering and
coming in because I feel like there's so
much that we have to learn about what
incarcerated women has to go through I'm
giving 50% of whatever I made from my
album back into re-entry programming so
two weeks ago I had a session and I was
talking to the women about what kinds of
programs where do you want this money to
go hands down they started sharing with
me about how there's not enough reentry
programs there's not enough just to get
food stamps as difficult just to get a
roof over your head is difficult just to
get a job as difficult so how am I
supposed to not come back in jail when
all the basic parts of life are
basically taken from me what are the
women tell you that you sing with who
are moms behind bars
two days ago I had a woman break down
into tears saying that I just want to be
with my kids you know we're doing an
opening exercise of you know how are you
feeling today and she just started
crying like I'm
I'm a mom I don't want to be here I want
to go home I want to be with my kids you
know they're struggling and I and I hear
that a lot for people who listen to your
music and who end up watching this video
and watching your album being recorded
in the jail what do you hope they walk
away with I really hope that they walk
away questioning about the systems that
we have and are they restorative and are
they transformative just asking that
question to really being able to see the
power that music has when we share it
with each other especially in places
that are in extreme confinement in
isolation and how you can actually see
how music is so expansive and Liberatore
at least for the moment three that I
hope that they would resonate with my
songs and feel inspired by them and feel
uplifted by them or even feel heard by
them I want people to feel heard through
music that if there are voices out there
that don't that don't feel heard that
somewhere in you a song that I wrote
would say oh wow I feel heard because
someone's written about something that I
resonate
across the country people are looking
for justice
our leaders tell us that only criminals
are punished and imprisoned civil rights
are protected and all people are treated
with dignity but that isn't our reality